hello and welcome to this video playing
yeah could be angel on hell
we don't know to 801 maybe the date of
birth oh this is a funny line that
seemed a fanatic see for now I have to
remember all the all the fun stuff that
just happened
yeah this shouldn't work at all Quincy
for
um and now yeah it would have been
better if I knew beforehand what you do
now
but I think a3 is probably the move is
there something even better I mean I
could have taken on before after Knight
takes c3 which is of course um a huge
advantage as well but you know
okay now him um Bishop age six Queen to
e7 if I take there are a couple of times
at the end I still cannot grab on c3 I
mean this is going to get the material
back so let's do that the piece back I
mean have taken g7
okay yeah Queenie form this is a threat
so let's take
so yeah Queen t2 there's a chick get
another chick how do we play that
I quickly want the bishop on d3 and the
rook on e1 so Bishop e2 is just not not
going to cut it okay you know know that
I think I made a mistake yeah I should
have thought about this for a moment
because here Queen before is simple and
very strong
the knight is not having any square
radio need e5 okay it's the only square
and then you go back and whites position
is fantastic you cannot cancel due to
Bishop h6 winning the exchange and that
means you have to go King evade and then
just play normal chess like whatever
this and it's terrible
I've got the bishop I cannot cancel much
more space pawn on e5 and so on engine
is close to +2 Queen g7 is not as
convincing I mean it is good for white
of course but not as clear as it should
be like exactly the game I'm a pawn up
and I have from disturb blacks position
with the Queen on g7 but it's not not as
great as the other lines also here took
and here should really move the King
King you want is the best move you know
unsurprisingly this is a sale pin that
is not really great you cannot cancel
now so it's best to move the King and
get this tempo it checked me Bishop d3
okay green g2 ISM have caused a big
mistake but it's very difficult to play
this position I've basically taking this
in the near future and I still have yeah
a huge advantage based on the black King
position only aid which is much easier
to attack than mine okay guys thanks for
watching